- Michael did actually cut
to the heart of the problem
but I approach the same problem
from a somewhat different perspective
really looking for more
by my experience in their
arms control negotiations,
and when you sit at the table
things look quite different often.
I don't see many students in the audience
but for those who are present
that can tell you that
Uh, that books like
Getting To Yes
don't actually reflect anything
that goes on at the negotiating table.
Yes it's a great book to teach,
but it's not a good book to follow
as you negotiate treaties.
So I would say that yes
we are at a really critical juncture.
Maybe we're already
actually past the juncture.
Honestly as I do not see much
hope in saving the existing
network of arms control treaties.
I don't see much hope for extending even
the new star treaty.
I think we're entering the world of
an unregulated arms race.
Maybe not so much in numbers
as in on new capabilities,
but these new capabilities
make war more likely.
Let me cut at this problem
at several levels.
On the more technical levels
or the arms control actual level is that
well if you look at the
INF treaty, especially,
I don't see much use
for existing procedures
and mechanisms to resolve concerns.
To me the situation
with the Russian missile
violating the INF treaty or other;
the U.S.
accusations of such violation.
Well, in fact, it looks quite similar.
We had similar cases before
while I was still at the foreign ministry.
And let me tell you back
yeah, that's like already
many years ago, but back then
similar issues were resolved
in a very different way.
The way it was tackled
by both sides on nowadays
simply did not allow for
any resolution whatsoever.
That's really why the treaty collapsed.
I do not really try to claim that I know
for sure whether there
was a violation or not
and frankly it actually doesn't matter.
What really matters from my view,
from a practitioner's point of view,
is the fact that there was
a chance to resolve that
and the chance was not taken.
Second; a big issue now
sort of the higher level.
The big issue is
so what do we address in arms control?
That has been the really
fundamental difference
that really came all to the floor
especially all clearly during the Obama
years.
Do we deal with nuclear weapons?
or do we deal with military capabilities?
The United States really tried very hard
to reduce nuclear weapons, yes,
that was the Prague speech.
And everything
to which Russia actually said
but nuclear weapons is just
one part of military balance.
Why don't we tackle things
like missile defense and long
range conventional weapons?
Oh, the difference is to an
extent actually philosophical,
but also quite practical.
During world war II the humankind
lost about 50 million people.
Using weapons that were
really quite primitive
from today's point of view.
So, um.
If we just eliminate nuclear weapons
do we save the humankind
or do we open gates for
a new conventional global war?
We don't have an answer.
I'm not trying to answer it.
I'm just saying that we
need to think about that.
All the trends are not very optimistic.
Yes let me be actually very
cynical here and even brutal.
Yes at the end of the cold war
and for the following 25 years
the United States did possess the monopoly
on advanced conventional weapons.
We talk two Wars in the Gulf,
we talk the Balkans, we talk Libya.
Well it was really wonderful world where
it was possible to reduce
reliance on nuclear weapons,
because we got wonderful non-nuclear
capabilities.
Well really let's go back to the 70's.
The war in Vietnam ended.
He said it was a defeat;
he said the United States
would not really go to
war for a very long time.
Why? Because the traditional
or conventional forces
were unusable, yes, the Soviet union lived
through the same
experience in Afghanistan.
I would say that after
Vietnam and Afghanistan
the world entered
a qualitatively new
stage.
The stage of peaceful foreign policy.
The stage when Clausewitz
was actually wrong
because war could no
longer be continuation.
So policy by other means, yes,
unfortunately that stage
was very short-lived,
because now we got advanced
conventional weapons
quite precise on not
much collateral damage.
We don't go to the battlefield.
Yes and things are really wonderful.
What happened in 2015;
it was the first use
of similar weapons by Russia
on battlefield in Syria.
So the monopoly was lost.
What do we see now?
Nuclear air launch cruise missiles
low yield warheads for Trident
look and things like that.
The Suwalki Gap like in Europe
and generally big Russian
Military threat to NATO.
Well I think it's
important all to understand
all the nuclear capabilities
and conventional capabilities,
Oh I'm sorry,
are universally related.
Well, in fact, Russia now all says no
we now got conventional deterrents
we don't have to rely on nuclear weapons.
That's really wonderful.
Yes, well, somehow NATO does
not see that as wonderful.
So, yes, that's kind of
all the second level.
Isn't the third level
that I think needs to
be addressed to understand why
we see all the dismantlement
of the arms control framework.
Is the broader concept
of international law,
international regimes,
and multilateralism.
The dominant perception in the west,
not just the United States,
is that we are good guys,
because we are for international law
and multi-lateral approaches.
Even Russia is not.
Well that's actually not true.
Well in fact Russia is a conservative
international law
multilateralist country.
Yes, it adheres to
conservative old, you know,
kind of fundamentals of
international law; Sovereign States.
You're not bound by international regime
unless you express who's agreed to that
for treaty to enter into force
everyone should sign
and things like that.
He's in, he's in the West
after the end of the cold war
it was more like the
majority actually rules.
So
the majority of States agree
that something is a good thing.
So, yes, we perceive going
with that policy.
Well just recall in the 90's
we developed a concept of
humanitarian intervention.
Well it actually does violate
traditional international law.
Yes that's a gap actually
in the body of law.
Well, since it's for a very good reason.
Well, let's actually go ahead.
Some States might not support it, yes,
and veto it at the United
Nations security council,
but we do it for all the common good.
Uh, we go to war over Casola.
Well, that actually did
violate the U.N. charter,
but it was for very good reasons.
Yes and then we recognized
independence of Casola.
In 2009 the United States
did file a fascinating legal
justification for that.
Well, it was called the U.S. Legal Opinion
on The Independence of Casola.
Surprise surprise in 2014, um,
Moscow took that document
and to the last word
implemented it in Crimea.
Yes, but we don't accept that because
that was
that was for a bad reason.
So, uh, we are into
this conflict between
two conceptions of international law.
What as we have this fundamental conflict
and we don't really talk about it much
at least in the West.
We do see and we are concerned
about what we see on the surface.
On the surface is
the dismantlement
of the arms control regimes.
Can we overcome that?
I think chances are low.
Yes the chances are low because
we talk about all things
all that are like on the surface.
Like the threat of war in general
or nuclear war specifically.
And we do not even try
to seek some kind
of a common position on
the bigger questions.
What's international law?
What is strategic stability?
What we should account for
as we write new treaties.
As long as we do not address these things.
Well,
always, I agree with you.
I'll go to church put a candle,
yes, and hope well that we all survive.
And I can tell you the down the road
survival will be
much more difficult.
To be honest the Cold War
standoff
with nuclear weapons was
nice, stable, understandable.
I would feel quite comfortable
right now to be honest
but we are entering
the era of new weapons,
of hypersonic weapons.
when leaders will have
two or three minutes
to make a decision.
Yes, in this world,
no, seriously.
Back during the cold war
you see
the opponents missiles flying.
Yes, and you got 20 to
40 minutes to think.
To verify the warning, to
connect to the opponent,
and ask
Oh what the hell is going?
Well, now you've got two or three minutes.
So also you have to react on first warning
and what's, uh, the
likely mode of reaction?
(thumb thumps on desk)
Yes it's actually the buttons, right.
We lived through a similar period.
A quite short period, though, in like 83'.
When American short range
intermediate range missiles
in Europe could reach
Moscow in seven minutes.
That challenge was resolved
in 87' by the INF treaty.
Given the state of relationship
between the Western Russia
I do not see such a treaty
or something similar in
the foreseeable future.
So let's enjoy life and pray.
Thank you.